- I definitely find
specifically with "Boyfriend"
because it was such a huge part
of me finding my own identity
and embracing my queerness.
And it like, makes me emotional
every time I talk about it.
But it was such a like
a key to a gate for me.
- Yeah.
- And to stepping into
myself wholly in a way
that I never knew if I was
gonna be privileged enough
to find those pieces of myself
and exist as that person, right.
'Cause that's like the fear.
The fear is that you
exist as yourself wholly
and the world cracks
open and everything ends,
and all the lights go out.
And when the song came out
and when I saw that people were
emotionally connecting to it
I think I was really
panicked for some reason.
Just 'cause I wasn't expecting it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then over time it was like,
it melded into this gorgeous,
like, something meaningful
for me being something
meaningful for others.
I'm sure you've had that before.
- Yeah.
- It becomes this like,
especially when it's something
about, you know, identity
and queerness and how
people view themselves.
- Something so personal and intimate.
- And finding empowerment in it
when it's something that can sometimes
feel very heavy to carry alone, identity.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I've found it incredibly special
and meaningful and such a surprise.
Such a beautiful surprise.
- Well we have a surprise for you.
- You have a surprise for me?
- Yes, we do.
- What does that mean?
- In honor of over one
million records sold, ma'am,
we're excited to present
you with the RIAA Platinum
(audience drowning Kelly out)
- Oh my God.
(Kelly making laser sounds)
Thank you so much.
- I was so excited when we
found out you were getting it.
I was like I wanna give it to her.
Dove's latest single is called "Bad Idea"
and it's available wherever
you get your music.
Check it out, y'all.